well it is a family tragedy with few  answers so far over the weekend metro  police say an off-duty north las vegas  police officer shot and killed his  daughter before taking his own life this  was sunday morning near lake mead and  mlk detectives say a man was arguing  with his wife when he pulled out a gun  she and their son were shot during a  struggle before they got out to call for  help but their daughter was killed  the mother and the son then fled from  the residence  to the nearby neighbor's house and the  female was stating that her husband was  currently inside the house and had tried  to kill her  identities of the victims have not been  released